you know we need another power source  hey  hey  if we could miniaturize an arc reactor  oh that's a dumb idea what we need is  vibranium with the right juice it can  act as a self-sustaining energy source  yeah now you're thinking two bed pops  used up the last of it during the war  not all of it  where did you get this this kind of  stuff pops up all over the globe you  just got to have the right hook up i  might have just the guy  ulysses claw no tony absolutely not i'm  sorry are you allowed to say that to  people in my tax bracket tony in case  you forgot stark industries is not in  the business of fraternizing with black  market arms dealers she's right tony i  agree wait what listen things go south  shareholders are gonna flip unless we  secure some kind of diplomatic cover we  send roadie there he's u.s air force and  he's the company's military liaison  we're all above board i think that's a  great idea excellent eyes dotted t's  crossed pep drop the purchase order